out here when it's really cold here in
the Arctic step through and you get cold
feet and mean the end of your toes the
guys want to shoot director photography
and I are gonna go across some of this
stuff we're gonna walk and I'm gonna
probe with the ice axe and see what we
see and I think he's gonna try to get a
shot on the other side of this and we've
walked through a little bit and there's
definitely like you know it's it's
sloppy really slippery in order to avoid
that happening we're gonna stick around
and kind of walk in the snow and it's a
good likelihood that we'll be it will be
kicking up water while we do it now that
we've tested the thickness of the ice
the crews gonna go ahead and cross these
small patches with snowshoes
we're following sue through some willows
and snow is pretty deep there and if you
don't go fast you're gonna get stuck
he's been in doubt through all the loud
it took us a little while to get out of
the snow but we dug it out to get shots
baskets lids old camp little time stuff
now we get fish two shots on life below
zero just arrives young location we're
about ten miles outside of Norfolk we're
cutting some trees down with the
hailstones climbing up the tree please
our GoPro in the tree hoping the tree
goes down the way we got the GoPro set
we think you guys this way yeah yeah
um so today we got to use our GoPro
cameras we've got some great tracking
shots with the hailstones out on the
river and lit up chop trees with them I
think we got a few good shots out there
today